[Music]
at xbox our passion is to help you find
and play the games that you love you
know i love the art form of video games
i think we tell stories that bring
people together whether it's competing
or whether it's cooperative this is just
what gaming should be about
[Music]
[Music]
wow after all this time
it's special to be back here with xbox
fans around the world
i mean just look at this stage
that alone shows you how far we've all
come since 2001.
my name is robbie bach and i had the
privilege of being in charge of xbox
until i retired from microsoft in 2010.
now when we started xbox 20 years ago
the original idea was a business venture
a way for microsoft to get into the
living room
but as we assembled our team and got to
work
xbox quickly blossomed into a new vision
for what games could be
an ethernet port to connect players over
the internet at broadband speeds
a built-in hard drive to help games
evolve beyond the limitations of disks
and cartridges
a global dedicated online service to let
you play with old and new friends alike
no matter where they are
these were audacious groundbreaking
ideas at the time
but they were all so risky
we faced skeptics and doubters i'll be
honest and say inside and outside of
microsoft
we had missteps along the way
there were lots of challenges involved
in getting that first xbox out the door
in a way that was true to our vision
so when i think about what it took to
bring xbox to life i always remember
that success was not guaranteed
and it was your passion for what xbox is
that transformed that vision into
reality
a vision only comes to life when others
share a belief in what's possible and
for that we are grateful to all of you
our partners developers around the world
and most of all our fans
[Music]
microsoft is going to make a game
console we weren't sure how we were
going to do it risk was enormous
microsoft was this dominant company of
the era but success or even survival was
anything but preordained
we started to ship quality games and at
the same time we weren't doing anything
in the console space one day these guys
from the directx team walked in
we just thought of ourselves kind of
that rebels of a weird combination of
craziness and genius we were a renegade
team
a lot of our thinking was focused on
making the very best games that really
meant something for us
we wanted to make a console designed to
be easy and fun to make games on
we were trying to crash meetings and get
traction on this thing
we were an annoyance you're proposing
taking money away from office in order
to fund some
game system balmer understood where the
money came from steve looked at the xbox
idea and saw insanity wait just one
minute before you answer what's the hard
drive gonna cost what's the ethernet
port gonna cost
there's no way
everything about making a console is
hard we made this little device it was
held together by chewing gum and pace
and it doesn't turn on and it became
clear that there was just some really
big challenges for us
the duke wasn't a small controller you
had to have gorilla hands to work with
this thing
it doesn't matter what your technology
is if you don't have the games we were
done they had this new thing called halo
forza was built as an epic racing game
gears of war was appealing to a hardcore
gamer we were focused on having all of
our games prepped for e3 and you're
always just one catastrophic bug away
from not making it
what's going on
the red ring of doubt microsoft brand is
on the line the microsoft name's on the
line it's insane to launch a game
console when you're microsoft you made
freaking windows in a spreadsheet it was
chaotic chaos total chaos our goal is to
continue to innovate across all
platforms bridge the gap between
traditional and cloud-based games and
then sometimes there's surprises that
come out of nowhere
we are no longer in the microsoft
playbook
power on the story of xbox is a six part
documentary series that release on
december 13th across a variety of video
platforms
so the project began almost three years
ago with a simple question
is there a compelling story behind the
history of xbox
the answer it turns out was yes
absolutely
so we partnered with an emmy
award-winning documentary film team to
really dig in and help bring the story
to life
at its core it's a story about how xbox
started as a passion project from a
small group of gamers within microsoft
and grew to become a source of joy for
xbox players around the world
whether you've been here for the entire
20 years or you have just joined us
we're excited to have you with us today
now we're going to relive some of our
favorite moments here's some words of
wisdom from our very own bill spencer
and definitely have a little bit of fun
well thanks rock and it really is an
honor to have you here believe it or not
i'm a big fan of yours for instance i
know that you're a five-time wwf
champion
not to mention one of the top
entertainers in the world
bill i'm very flattered i'm a big fan of
yours as well
for instance the rock knows you're the
chairman and chief software architect of
the microsoft corporation a leading
worldwide provider of software for the
personal computer
thank you rock i'm i'm very flattered
myself by creating windows by creating
windows in 1983 a multitasking graphical
user interface environment that runs on
ms dos based computers along with
windows nt and windows 2000 completely
self-contained operating systems that
feature networking uh symmetric
multi-processing multi-threading
and
security bill you've certainly
revolutionized the technology we know
today
wow
rock that is impressive so
for the first time let me now unveil
xbox
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i think this is going to be looked back
on as the golden age video game
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone i'm phil spencer known on
xbox as p3
i've been playing video games pretty
much my whole life
i actually joined this company as an
intern but i was still in school a long
time before xbox was even a concept
so when i think about 20 years of xbox
and what games mean to all of us
i always come back to the fact that
around the world gaming is all about
people
that's it
games are all about real people coming
together to create experiences and
relationships that cross geographies and
cultures and age and all the things that
can separate people in other parts of
life
personally i've been fortunate to see
that power of gaming to connect people
in a few ways at work the best part of
my job is spending time with the
ridiculously talented teams both here at
xbox and across our industry
you gaming creators around the world are
at the forefront of the world's most
exciting art form
but the reality is that as an industry
none of our work comes to life until
it's enjoyed by our players
you the global gaming community are a
powerful force and it is you've made our
passion as popular and important as it
is today
pretty much every day when i'm off work
i'm on xbox i'm chatting with friends
we're driving jeeps off cliffs and forza
i'm trying new games in game pass
this is where we live and we've all seen
how important and real those human
relationships can be
especially in the face of real life
adversity
so when i think about 20 years of xbox i
think about you
our community and our creators
and i want you to know that i'm
dedicated team xbox is dedicated and
this company is dedicated to continuing
to invest
listen and learn as we build the best
most welcoming and most fun
entertainment ecosystem anywhere on
earth and beyond
at xbox we're on a mission to bring the
joy and community of gaming to everyone
and we're honored that you've joined us
for the last 20 years and we can't wait
to build the future together
so thank you and see you online
[Music]
his name is jacob i met him like three
years ago on call of duty black ops
three so over the next year he quickly
became one of our best friends we're
meeting for the first time but of course
it was only online i've never seen him
in person tanner lives in spokane
washington and i was like bro i'm gonna
be in canada he's like bro no way he's
here
it's just so crazy
now let's pack up and head to st louis
[Music]
that's why we're friends
[Applause]
since the launch of xbox one we've
listened to you the community of xbox
gamers and we're grateful for your
continued feedback
we continue to deliver monthly platform
feature updates that enhance your gaming
experience and your response to the
updates continues to motivate us
last year the team decided to tackle a
feature that has been consistently at
the top of your request list
and while we weren't sure it was
possible
today
i'm pleased to announce xbox one
backward compatibility
your xbox 360 games
the games you've invested your time and
money in
and the games you want to continue to be
play
will be playable natively on your xbox
one
[Applause]
you asked for more games to join our
backward compatibility catalog from the
biggest blockbusters to cult classics
and we listened today we are celebrating
our anniversary by adding more than 70
original xbox and xbox 360 games to our
backward compatibility catalog
the entire max payne series is now
playable on xbox series x series s and
xbox one consoles for the very first
time
the entire fear franchise can now be
played on our latest machines
games like dead or alive ultimate and
star wars jedi knight 2 jedi outcast are
once again playable on a new generation
of consoles
all original xbox games will look better
than ever on all modern consoles
every one of the titles added today will
benefit from auto hdr and many will
enjoy increased frame rates with fps
boost including a wider range of our
existing backward compatible titles like
the gears of war franchise the fable
franchise
cameo and sonic generations
at xbox we are committed to preserving
the games that you love enhanced by the
latest technology while staying true to
the original creator's vision
what better way to celebrate the past 20
years than by playing the iconic games
that helped define it thank you for
being with us on every step of this
journey
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you ever wonder what the bottom of an
avatar shoe looks like
well bam there it is
[Music]
wow next time
[Music]
all right xbox fans the time has come
can you believe it has been 20 years
since i stood on that ces stage in las
vegas and helped launch the original
xbox now of course i nailed all the cool
buzzwords the rock's here to say that
that can't be farther from the truth
symmetric multi-processing completely
self-contained operating system and how
about that look i mean the outfit the
glasses who wears glasses inside and i
even had hair back then those were the
days the good old days now thank the
lord i left the fanny pack in my closet
all right well i hope you had a chance
to watch red notice on netflix over the
weekend now here's the thing we built a
kick-ass vault inspired by the film with
some amazing treasures and artifacts
from xbox over the last 20 years now
look my co-stars ryan reynolds and gal
gadot being the master thieves that they
are they are hell-bent on getting into
the vault and getting their hands on
these artifacts themselves so i need
your help i need you to break into the
xbox vault yourself by heading over to
the site below
now i'm excited to tell you we got
hundreds and hundreds of amazing prizes
including an oil painting of yours truly
from that moment 20 years ago the look
the glasses the hair the whole thing is
there and custom xbox red notice
hardware game pass collectors cards we
got hundreds and hundreds of them for
you guys and last but not least
three cleopatra eggs just like the ones
in red notice all right it's time for me
to go and hit the iron paradise and show
master chief what uh real guns look like
you never cease to amaze the rock enjoy
the rest of the show
[Music]
oops
[Music]
all right i think i'm gonna be going to
bed now
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome kiara reeves
hello los angeles
yeah the feeling of walking the streets
of the future
is really going to be breathtaking
you're breathtaking
you're all breathtaking
[Applause]
more than just fun it's an activity that
brings people from all walks of life
from all over the world together
[Music]
congratulations thank
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
online
[Music]
the vision that we've worked on for so
long you see it in real products xbox
one x the most powerful console ever
made
that journey from vision to reality
isn't always a direct path
we see a future where you're instantly
absorbed in your games
where worlds are even more like-like
immersive
responsive and surprising
we centered on this idea putting the
player at the center
really freeing up the player to play the
games that they want with the people
they want on the devices that they want
to play
[Music]
xbox will be the platform that underpins
gaming experiences for the globe
that's the vision
it will connect people
it will empower creators to achieve
things they never could before
it will break down barriers
that's what i believe
[Music]
a milestone like the 20th anniversary of
xbox is more than a chance to reflect on
all we've done and everything our
players have taught us
with 23 studios across xbox game studios
and bethesda all pouring their
incredible passion into creating new
worlds and amazing experiences the
future of gaming is awe-inspiring
at xbox our love for players starts with
our love for games and the creators who
make them
we know that to reach more gamers in
more parts of the world we need to keep
bringing more creative voices and
perspectives to the table
fostering a community as diverse as the
world we live in and inclusive of all
that makes each of us who we are
that's why we relentlessly invest to
make it easier and faster for developers
to build the games we love we've driven
innovation to enable developers to build
accessibility features into their games
like remappable controls and adjustable
color or text for players who are
visually impaired
we collaborate with creators to
encourage representation of diverse
characters for stories that can open our
eyes and our hearts to new points of
view and we're committed to bringing
those incredible games to every gamer on
the planet by making it possible for
anyone to play any game
anywhere we do that with game pass
bringing you hundreds of titles from
hidden gems to the biggest hits playable
across all devices we do that with our
consoles the most affordable and
powerful console lineup with xbox series
s and x
and we do that with things like the xbox
adaptive controller which has unlocked
the joy of gaming for over 400 million
players with disabilities
when everyone plays we all win it isn't
just a tagline it's a core principle
that inspires everything we do
so please join us as we look forward to
the next 20 years and more as we unleash
creativity embrace a global community
and delight gamers
everywhere
together thank you for being the core of
what makes xbox great
[Music]
our duty as soldiers is to protect
humanity
whatever the cost
[Music]
hello master chief
[Music]
i'm so fortunate to be able to work and
play in this incredible sci-fi universe
of halo
like marvel and star wars halo is a
universe where hundreds of stories can
be told and where millions of
experiences can be shared
halo began 20 years ago as the defining
experience for xbox
and thanks to you it's now a global pop
culture phenomenon
whether it's the highly anticipated halo
tv series coming to paramount plus next
year which you just saw a glimpse in
that live-action teaser or stepping back
into the boots of master chief in halo
infinite this december
the halo universe continues to expand in
new and thrilling ways
because of your passion for halo
and your constructive feedback we gave
halo infinite more time
to refine it for everyone that has been
with us from the beginning
and for anyone who's just getting
started
this game is returned to our roots with
an epic campaign and a deeply rewarding
multiplayer and we can't wait for you to
jump into this all-new halo experience
while the master chief is the hero of
halo
our fans are its heart and soul
and we at 343 are proud to celebrate 20
years of halo with you in a very special
way
enjoy
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
hello halo community from all of us at
343 industries
[Applause]
to everyone who played in the recent
multiplayer flights your passion and
feedback and spectacular gameplay clips
inspired all of us as we made the final
push to get halo infinite ready for
launch as a thank you and to celebrate
our 20th anniversary we wanted to do
something special so let me hand the mic
to tom french creative director for halo
infinite multiplayer tom
thank you joseph on behalf of the entire
halo team it's my honor and privilege to
announce that your spartan journey
begins today
right now you can download and start
playing season one of halo infinite's
free to play multiplayer beta on xbox
one series s x and pc this is the
kickoff of our season and you'll have
access to all the maps core modes
academy features and the full battle
pass to unlock and your progression will
carry over when we officially release
the game on december 8th this is an
amazing moment for our team to get to
celebrate this as we finally get to
release the game and play with you
online see you online spartans
[Applause]
we built this facility off the grid to
train the next generation of spartans
to be a spartan you must become
the impossible
greeting spot it would be my pleasure to
serve at your side
an electric kill
on your feet
ninja
[Music]
[Music]
zone captured
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you